as you all know this is the
situation people doing well by the way
uh and when T prayers are established at
night it is really really hard for us to
even fit people in very very narrow uh
passages you know we got people praying
out
[Music]
for
so it's like daugh pray and
puddles
the rain here and this p is not exactly
the best in situations we've got bits
and people from the market laying
[Music]
around so just to remind people your
donations will be greatly appreciated
from the angle of just helping Muslims
pray to Allah subhana wa tala this is
the most important thing this is still
not a suitable situation to be in for
families and children to come and pray
you know it's not exactly health and
safety issue at hand you know if people
were to come here in large amounts and
great number but let's not forget that
this is a message for you not just for
us it's a community in which in theory
one day benefit you it will be
prosperous it will be profitable for you
all inshah not just in this life but
also in the after
life this is just a short message with
regards our uh Brothers in d sunah are
trying to establish a Masid and they
have been do trying for a while and um
alhamdulillah there's an opportunity now
to give charity to establish this Masid
uh whereby the five daily prayers are
prayed the call to Islam is established
whereby there will be CL classes for new
Muslims and also specific sisters
lessons youth projects Quran lessons for
those who want to learn how to read
Quran Arabic language
likewise uh will be um lessons will be
established and um alhamdulillah they
have been calling non-muslims to Islam
for uh for a while and many people have
become Muslim alhamdulillah by the grace
of Allah so giving charity towards a s
project this will be a continuous
charity even if you're in your grave for
indeed
Allah has
[Music]
mentioned indeed those who give charity
male and female those who give to Allah
goodly loan for them their reward will
be magnified and they will have a
blessed
reward whatever you give of anything
that you have then Allah subh will
replace it and he's the best of those
who provide and give sustenance give
charity establish the Sunnah the mass of
Sunnah that establish the
true and the spread of the sun of the
messenger and we encourage each other to
cooperate
upon and cooperate upon righteousness
and piety may Allah forgive us our
shortcomings